[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
se cumplieron tres años del brexit que
firmó la salida de Reino Unido de la
Unión Europea Cuáles han sido los
impactos de estos para los socios
latinoamericanos del gobierno británico
para hablar de ello nos acompaña James
Doris él es el director adjunto para las
Américas de la cancillería británica
James Gracias por acompañarnos
Bueno como ya lo decíamos el 31 de enero
se cumplieron estos tres años del brexit
Y a propósito el Primer Ministro Richie
sunak dijo que esto había sido un
momento Para aprovechar las libertades
sin embargo del otro lado Reino Unido es
la única Economía del g7 que podría
contraerse En 2023 cuál es su balance
del brexit
Bueno estamos en ese otro día Como he
mencionado tres años ya han pasado
estamos hablando de empresas proceso
largo hemos logrado mucho como
resolviendo a las diferencias los puntos
para para resolver entre nosotros y los
27 países miembros de la Unión Europea
el Reino Unido por supuesto sigue siendo
un país europeo lo que no no somos ahora
es país miembro es pacíficamente de la
Unión Europea también vale recordar que
estamos hablando de un grupo de países
que sí que siguen siendo
aliados sumamente importante para
nosotros un ejemplo de de la abundancia
la importancia de esta Alianza es
nuestra respuesta
conjunto compartido en contra de la
invasión totalmente inaceptable ilegal
aparte de Ucrania pero la segunda por
cuenta Cuáles son las ventajas Dónde
están las oportunidades oportunidades
incluyendo para los países de esta
región un ejemplo bueno son los tratados
de comercio y estamos entrando en ya
hemos acordado
algunos estamos en el proceso de
negociación algunos tratados de comercio
libre con los países de la región por
ejemplo el tratado de libre comercio con
Colombia entre en vigor el año pasado
y otro de los avances que han hecho
ustedes es que a partir del nueve de
noviembre de 2022 levantaron las visas
durante seis meses para los ciudadanos
de Perú y Colombia Cuál es ese balance
de estos pocos meses de la medida y
sobre todo se espera que se aplique Lo
mismo para Ecuador no tengo cifras
precisas pero hablando estoy en
instrumento en Colombia y hablando con
gente acá el hecho que ya no es
necesario obtener una visita británica
para visitar como turista para visitas
cortas es algo muy bienvenido y es el
mismo caso de Perú estuve en Lima hace
poco y el hecho que estamos de esa
manera facilitando el intercambio humano
es algo importante para para todos
nuestros países y se puede venir lo
mismo con Ecuador bueno tomará tiempo
tomamos esa decisión uno por uno pero
por elemento hemos tomado esas dos pero
las relaciones bilaterales con Ecuador
son sumamente importantes
incluyendo pensando en lo internacional
incluyendo porque ahora Ecuador es
miembro del Consejo de Seguridad de las
Naciones Unidas
a propósito que estamos hablando de
Colombia el gobierno británico ha
respaldado el proceso de paz que realizó
el entonces gobierno de Juan Manuel
Santos con la guerrilla de las FARC
Ustedes han financiado un poco este
proceso de paz y ahora cuál es la
postura de Reino Unido frente a la
política de paz total del presidente de
colombiano Gustavo Petro que lo que
quiere pretender hacer es negociar con
otros grupos armados diferentes a las
guerrillas
unas palabras sobre el acuerdo de 2016 y
como país somos muy comprometidos en
ayudar a apoyar a Colombia a los
colombianos en la implementación de eso
fue muy bienvenido por ejemplo el la
extensión del mandato de las visión de
verificación de las Naciones Unidas hace
poco en dos capítulos el capítulo de
rural y el capítulo étnico y en el
consejero el consejo de seguridad de las
Naciones Naciones Unidas es el Reino
Unido que está como encargado del tema
si pensamos en las ambiciones del señor
presidente de Colombia señor Gustavo
Petro estamos muy comprometidos con
Colombia con
su ambición de lograr la seguridad y una
paz duradera una paz que
el país necesito y merezca tanto quiero
pasar al tema de Perú un tema que usted
claramente conoce porque fue embajador
allí entre 2010 y 2014 y usted ha pedido
moderación y respeto tanto a los
manifestantes como la fuerza pública en
medio de las protestas anti
gubernamentales donde los manifestantes
una de las exigencias es la renuncia de
la presidenta Dina boluarte quien no fue
elegida popularmente sino que asumió el
cargo luego de que el expresidente Pedro
Castillo fuera destituido por el
congreso el Primer Ministro británico
Richie sunak le dio la bienvenida a
boluarte en ese aspecto Cómo entender
entonces la postura de Reino Unido
frente a un gobierno que no ha sido
elegido democráticamente Y cómo
garantizan ustedes o qué hacen ustedes
para ayudar a garantizar el respeto de
los Derechos Humanos
lo que han hecho en Perú es seguir un
proceso democrático
constitucional y hemos dado la
bienvenida al como resultado del
seguimiento de este proceso
constitucional y
rápidamente Confirmamos nuestro apoyo
por la nueva presidenta a la señora
polate en Perú hablando de las
manifestaciones
lastimosamente como sabemos
personas han muerto en esas y la
violencia realmente no tiene ninguna
parte en ningún como proceso democrático
como estamos viendo y como el país está
como experimentando otra de las
situaciones difíciles en nuestra región
para retomar las palabras que usted
utilizó es Venezuela usted es el
gobierno británico dice que la única la
última asamblea nacional elegida
democráticamente fue la de 2015 donde lo
la oposición ganó y luego no reconocen
la asamblea que hubo posteriormente y
que es liderada por la mayoría chavista
en ese sentido Cuál es la relación del
gobierno británico con el gobierno de
Nicolás maduro y sobre todo ahora que
los mismos partidos opositores ya le
quitaron la presidencia interina que se
autoproclamó el opositor Juan guaidó y
dos Cuál es la postura de Reino Unido
frente a las elecciones de 2024 en
Venezuela
buenas preguntas bueno respetamos la
decisión de la asamblea nacional de 2015
de
pasar por el gobierno interino primero y
segundo por este puesto de
presidente interino constitucional y por
eso hemos dicho a unos pocos días
después de su decisión que ya no
reconocemos
la
presidencia de Juan guaidó como decimos
antes
al mismo tiempo y en la en la misma
declaración hicimos Claro que todavía no
reconocemos la legitimidad de nivel de
Nicolás y de su su gobierno porque no
reconocemos la legitimidad de la
elección presidencial ni de la como has
mencionado de la asamblea nacional hace
pocos años para para todos para todos
nosotros como país amigos de Venezuela
de los venezolanos y estamos muy
compromisos En eso como país amigo de
Venezuela vemos que tener a parálisis
para el país para sus ciudadanos tener
elecciones libres justas democráticas el
próximo año en 2024 es sumamente
importante y hay buenos ejemplos en esta
región de procesos democráticos
resultando en la elección de presidentes
de la izquierda
Sí en Colombia en Chile en Brasil por
ejemplo y a otros y le quiero volver a
preguntar sobre la democracia pero ahora
en Centroamérica porque usted hizo un
viaje en octubre de 2022 por varios
países de la región y por ejemplo
Nicaragua el gobierno británico lo ha
declarado como una crisis democrática
sobre todo que se ha empeorado desde las
elecciones locales en noviembre de 2022
en el Salvador usted se reunió con
organizaciones que denuncian violaciones
a los derechos humanos y en Nicaragua
sobre todo el gobierno británico ha
puesto la mirada a la persecución contra
los jueces especialmente contra quienes
trabajaron en la comisión internacional
contra la impunidad qué tan frágil es la
democracia allí Y empezamos con
la situación ya allá nos inquieta a más
hay prisioneros políticos hay abusos
graves de Derechos Humanos
hay grandes presiones en los medios hay
periodistas encarcelados y es otro país
como Venezuela que tiene una tradición
democrática sí ha tenido sus problemas
pero al mismo tiempo
evitar y evitar una catástrofe política
a un gastos de política y resolver las
diferencias
lo que tienen que hacer Son son
elecciones si en lo que está pasando en
Guatemala bueno en Guatemala en algún
país es bastante importante a tomar en
serio la lucha contra la corrupción
Guatemala no es país único porque hay
muchos muchos países casi todos los
países tienen un problema con la
corrupción pero el trabajo que estaba
haciendo así sí la comisión la comisión
guatemalteca contra la contra la
corrupción
fue fue algo importante y lo que estamos
viendo ahora con la persecución judicial
legal por medios de los que tenían
partes en eso es inquietante no
solamente para para la comunidad
internacional sino más que todo para los
guatemaltecos que que quieren que tienen
derecho a vivir en un país donde regla
la ley
bueno el sábado sí tuve el placer
francamente de visitar a el sábado
Guatemala también Honduras previamente
pero en el sábado como en todos los
países
insistimos en la importancia de los
Derechos Humanos es un tema que
[Música]
con el gobierno de salvadoreño
entendemos por qué han tomado que tomar
en serio
esa lucha contra el crimen organizado
allá porque el país y la gente tiene
tiene tiene un problema grande con
organizado al mismo tiempo como muchos
países en esa región han experimentado
vale al mismo tiempo a respetar a los
Derechos Humanos cuando están tomando
medidas necesarias para controlar a
controlar el primero
gracias por estar con nosotros aquí en
24 un placer preciosa hasta aquí la
entrevista sigan ustedes con más 24
[Música]